[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: All right,
how are you guys doing?
[CHEERING]
Thank you.
You know why?
This is such an amazing day.
All right, first of all, we're
going to talk about phases.
And there are two lectures
that I have introduced
this semester that are new, that
have never been seen before,
until right now.
One of them is this one.
Right, Dane, thank you.
And then, check this out,
this morning over the wires
comes this news.
And it's the Nobel
Prize in chemistry
this year was given to 3 of sort
of the founders of lithium ion
batteries.
And the other new
lecture that I'm
giving this semester,
later on, is
on the chemistry of batteries.
It's like coincidence?
[LAUGHTER]
I don't think so.
Did someone in Stockholm know?
I don't know.
But it's really, really cool.
And this is awesome.
And there's so much
great stuff online now
about lithium ion
batteries, because of this.
I mean there was before, but
there is a lot of press on this
now.
It's very interesting
to read about.
OK.
So now, what is happening?
I say the word
boiling all the time.
Right.
I've been saying it all the
time, especially the last week.
And I mean at home, too,
I'm saying boiling a lot.
And it's because it's a
proxy for bond strength,
intramolecular bond
strength and boiling,
I've been kind of
going back and forth.
Right.
But so, today, we're
going to go, what
is happening when you boil?
All right.
Well, you know that
you're changing a phase,
as you can see from this highly
accurate drawing of water
molecules in the
gas phase, water
molecules in the liquid phase.
But what's really
under the hood?
And of course, the
story starts with Otto.
Now who was Otto?
Otto Von Guericke.
Otto Von Guericke in the 1600s.
He was like-- you know what--
Aristotle.
Aristotle, he was all about
like nature abhors a vacuum.
Does it really?
I don't know.
I don't-- you know,
does nature really hate?
Like, let's try some stuff out.
Let's try to make a vacuum,
and see what happens.
So he figured out a
way to take these two
hemispheres, these
two big bowls,
and kind of pull
all the air out.
There he is.
He looks very happy there.
Right.
And he's pulling-- because
he's pumping the air out inside
of here, and look he did.
He went around the
countryside in Germany,
and he would attach--
gesundheit-- just attach eight
horses to one side, and
eight horses to another,
16 horses pulling.
Eight that way, eight
that way, and they
couldn't pull it apart.
This is what he did.
It doesn't look like
he's got a lot of crowd,
but maybe he did better.
I don't see any houses either.
I don't know where he is.
But that's the experiment
that he did all
throughout the countryside.
And he called it the
power of the vacuum.
Nature abhors a vacuum,
the power of the vacuum.
Power of the vacuum.
It's not the power
of the vacuum.
Oh, Otto, it's not the
power of the vacuum,
because vacuum has no power,
and nature doesn't hate it.
But pressure-- so
atmosphere has power.
Technically, it has force.
Atmosphere has pressure.
What he showed in
that experiment,
and if there's one
experiment I want
you to remember from this
class, it's not this one.
[LAUGHTER]
But this is a cool one.
But what he showed
wasn't the power vacuum,
he showed the power of one
atmosphere of pressure.
He showed the power of pressure.
And so we start.
Pressure is force over area.
Typical units would be like
newtons per meter squared,
right.
And if you're going
newtons per meter squared,
then this is called the pascal.
And for reference, if you
have one pascal, one pascal,
it's about the pressure of
a dollar bill, $1 resting
on a table.
I don't know.
Why do I use that one?
Because I remember it,
$1 resting on a table.
And so that's the force per area
of the bill resting on a table.
So if you had 100,000
of them, right,
if you had 100,000 of them,
and you stacked them up,
then that's one atmosphere.
That's just a different unit.
It's about 100,000 pascals.
So the power that he was
exhibiting in this experiment
is the power of the atmosphere.
We've got-- we've got atmosphere
all around us, pushing on us.
It's pushing on us.
And so, we got like a
car worth of atmosphere,
literally, on us, but
it's pushing on us
in all different directions.
And we're pushing back.
Luckily, we've got
stuff inside of us,
so we don't like implode.
Right.
That force is strong, and that's
a demonstration of how strong,
how much one atmosphere is.
Right.
It's force per area, the
power of one atmosphere.
Well, that's also directly
related to boiling.
And how do we get
from here to boiling?
Well, so we need a couple
of concepts, right.
So first, we need the
concept of evaporation.
And I'm going to use this--
I'm going to use this example
of like water molecules, right.
So this is a--
this is a glass of water.
Right.
And so, if I have
a glass of water,
I'm going to draw them like
these little things-- yeah,
and now molecules kind
of near the surface--
well, it could leave.
And that is-- that's a molecule,
not a v, right, and that's
evaporation, evaporation.
Evaporation.
But, you know, the
other way you could go
is, you could say, well, what
if there was this liquid here,
and you've got these
molecules, kind of like that.
And you had one here.
And it kind of comes back.
Well, that's condensation.
You guys kind of
know this, right?
Condensation.
Evaporation and condensation.
Oh, but this is not
what's interesting.
I mean it's interesting,
but it's-- but it's more
interesting now if
you close it off.
And so, let's do that with
these super amazing animations
here-- they're there.
Look at that.
OK.
So now what I've done, I've
got a liquid and a solid.
And in both cases,
there's a liquid.
You could have solid.
Molecules can come off.
We'll get to that.
How?
Why?
They can come off.
But now I've closed it.
Now if I close the
container, what
would happen if I
start with nothing?
So now I start with a liquid,
and I close it in a container.
You see-- look at the molecules.
They're kind of coming off.
And maybe they'll hit the
walls or bounce around,
maybe at some point, they'll
come back into the liquid.
Right.
OK.
So evaporation went that way.
Condensation went that way.
Now-- ah-- now,
if I were to plot,
if I were to close this and
plot, for example, a rate.
And I say, well, I want to
know how quickly evaporation
is happening.
It's just going
to keep happening.
I mean I'm starting with,
you see in the videos--
these videos are real--
you see it doesn't
stop happening.
right.
It keeps happening.
So if I have no vapor in there
to begin with, well, then,
OK, evaporation is
going to go like this.
All right, maybe this
is time, it is time.
And then-- so
that's evaporation.
But then, at a certain
time, at a certain point,
I'm going to have enough
gas molecules, gas water
molecules in there.
So it starts out
at 0, and they're
going to build up in there,
and at a certain point,
you got that.
Right.
And so, this would
be condensation.
OK.
We're starting with the
basics, condensation.
Right.
And then at a
certain point, they
reach what's called dynamic
equilibrium, dynamic eqm,
eqm is equilibrium.
So the dynamic equilibrium
is really important,
because what happens there
is nothing is stopping.
It's not the thing stopped.
You can see it in the videos.
I found it online,
so it must be right.
So like, you know,
it's continually going.
It's a dynamic process.
It's a dynamic equilibrium,
but they are equal.
That point that happens
in these containers,
you can measure the pressure.
That is very important.
Right.
Because it's exerting a
pressure on the container.
It's exerting a
pressure on the liquid.
Pressure.
Atmosphere.
Pressure, inside of a closed
container, vapor pressure.
P vapor.
That happens when you hit
that dynamic equilibrium.
Now why am I telling
you all this?
Well, the vapor
pressure is going
to be how we understand
phase change.
And so-- and so--
you kind of get a sense already,
kind of get a sense already,
that this is going
to be related--
this is related, you know,
this depends on the bonding.
Right.
So I just told you that
water was really special.
So that means that how it--
it's the bonding between
the water molecules
and how often can it
get out of the liquid,
it's related to the bonding.
Right.
So if you take molecules that
we talked about on Monday--
these are just from
Monday-- propane and butane,
now you understand, right?
Why is there this difference in
the vapor pressure of protane--
propane, and the vapor
pressure of butane?
Well, it's how
they bond together.
And you know exactly why.
Because these are only
able to do [INAUDIBLE]..
And so, this has a--
has a higher surface area.
We talk about this in
terms of the boiling point,
remember, as a proxy for
the intermolecular bonding
strength.
And now I'm giving you
the vapor pressure.
So this is the vapor pressure
of these things is different.
Those are measured-- those
are given a kilopascal.
So if it's water--
so the water vapor pressure--
right-- let's see, make
sure I get this value--
yes-- P--
I'll just put a Pv for water,
is about 2.3 kilopascal.
So it's a lot lower than those.
Right.
Those are-- now, in
atmospheres, and this
is going to be important,
0.02 atmospheres.
Just switching around
units, that's all.
It's same thing.
Gesundheit.
Right.
So now, if a liquid is- you
can think about this as,
well, this is a proxy already.
I can understand
this conceptually.
Right.
It's a proxy for the
intermolecular bonding.
If you take something
like glycerol--
well, glycerol is-- let's
draw glycerol just for fun.
Carbon, carbon, Oh-- let's
see, it's got another carbon,
OH, it's got another OH,
look at all that, OHs.
It's got some
hydrogens down here.
It's got another
hydrogen in there,
and it's got two more
hydrogens out here.
No, I am not paying
attention to VSEPR right now.
I'm just getting
it on the board.
But look-- but look at that.
Right away, you're like, oh,
look at those hydrogen bond
opportunities.
Yeah.
This could bond more strongly
than water to itself, right.
It's got all that
hydrogen bonding.
It's got even more than water.
And so the vapor pressure
of this is 0.01 pascal.
So much lower.
And as a general rule, we like
to compare everything to water.
So if something has a vapor
pressure that is higher
than water, so it's called
volatile, Pv greater than Pv
water, it is volatile.
It's a volatile liquid,
like butane and propane.
If it's less than Pv
water, then it's called--
here it comes-- all those
chemists-- non-volatile.
Look at that.
Look at that beautiful
naming originality.
OK.
But this is the
thing, right, I've
given you this concept
of vapor pressure.
I've talked about
it a little bit.
You can relate it to something
you just learned on Monday.
But I still have not
come back to boiling.
And that really is it.
It's that boiling is actually
understood by vapor pressure.
That is how we
understand boiling.
And so you can think
about it-- let's just
give it to you conceptually.
Right.
So if you had--
let's go back to
those buckets there.
Think of it-- we'll
go back to like
evaporation and condensation.
But now, instead of being
in a closed container,
right, now I'm outside.
So if I had, let's say I
had this container here.
And I've got all
these waters in it.
Right.
But now I'm outside.
So I've got the power of
one atmosphere, right.
One atmosphere.
Well, you know, now
you see, like, OK,
if a molecule is able to
evaporate from the liquid,
leave the liquid bonding
environment, breaking
the bond, that's
why we can relate it to
intermolecular forces, right.
It's breaking those
bonds in the liquid,
and becoming a gas
phase molecule.
It's changing its phase.
Well, you know,
then the question
is, is it like going to--
what's it going to do?
You know, is it going to
kind of hang out here?
And are the forces
of the atmosphere,
is the atmospheric pressure
going to kind of hold it
around there?
Or, is it going to
be able to leave?
Well, this is a very
simple conceptual picture.
Right.
If you thought that the
forces of the atmosphere
were going to always
hold it there,
then you'd say the
atmosphere is a container.
And it's not.
But, actually,
evaporation only happens
because a breeze can come
along and blow this away--
right-- out in the air.
So those forces are
super important,
because as soon as the
vapor pressure is greater
than the atmospheric
pressure, well,
now you can get a sense of
what-- the vapor pressure is
greater than the pressure
outside over that surface
of the air here, then
the molecule is just
going to fly right out
and power through it.
That is the
definition of boiling.
Boiling is a pressure effect.
It's that the vapor pressure
of this material, which
is related to how strongly it's
bonded in the liquid compared
to the gas phase, that that
goes higher than the surrounding
pressure.
That's the definition
of boiling.
So you can see why
water doesn't boil.
Like having a bucket of
water, and I watch it,
it's not going to boil.
0.02 atmospheres is
not greater than one.
Right.
But so I haven't
gotten there yet.
I haven't made it boil.
But I want to make a boil.
And that is where we go
next, because that is really
what temperature is.
See, the vapor
pressure is really
a link between
temperature and boiling.
It's the length that you need to
understand between temperature
and boiling.
The reason why-- when you
increase the temperature
of the water, the
reason why it boils
is because you change
its vapor pressure.
That's why it boils.
That's what boiling is.
OK.
It's when you get it above
the atmospheric pressure.
No.
OK.
So the-- so we got--
OK-- so are we--
where-- there we go--
we'll come to that in a minute.
So if I were to plot
now, the vapor pressure--
let's do this carefully here.
OK.
I'm going to make a plot of
the vapor pressure, Pv, right,
versus temperature.
So I just told you there's a
dependence on the temperature.
Right.
So versus temperature.
Let's go to-- oh, I don't know--
let's go to room temperature.
So around here, and I just
told you that at 0.022 for 25
C. OK, good.
So 0.02 for 25.
0.02 for 25 C. So that's
the vapor pressure.
That's the temperature.
But I also told
you that boiling--
if I'm at-- so this is 0-- but
I also told you that boiling--
so this would be
like one atmosphere.
Let's suppose the
units are atmospheres.
Right.
OK.
So I told you that
boiling happens--
now we know that water-- we
know what the answer is, right,
up here.
That's got to be boiling
for 100 C, right.
That's where the
water goes above
or meets the
atmospheric pressure,
and then goes above it.
So once the vapor
pressure-- so if this
is the vapor pressure of water,
this is what we have so far.
But we need more than that.
So you can say,
well, why is it--
so we know this--
why is it that if I
go to Denver, the--
so like this is in Boston--
this is in Boston.
This is Boston.
But if I live in Denver--
how many people live in Denver--
well, I mean you're not
living there now, but--
but, welcome to Boston.
Oh, ho, ho.
And if I go like this--
now see the thing is,
now you boil at-- this
is-- this is in Denver.
So you guys don't have
as much air in Denver.
The pressure in Denver is
0.83, 0.83 atmospheres.
But I just said
that, you know, you
boil when you have the
vapor pressure is higher
than the atmospheric pressure.
So that means,
whatever this curve
is, it means that
I'm going to boil
at a different temperature.
And it turns out that's 100,
and if you're in Denver,
it takes longer
to boil potatoes,
because the boiling
temperature is 95.
That's why.
But it's all because of this.
It's all because
of how evaporation
happens as it relates to
the atmospheric pressure.
Yeah, but-- the thing is,
though, what we need--
and by the way, you know, you
can go the other way, too.
Right.
You go up.
If you go below sea level,
then the atmospheric pressure
is higher.
So if you go to the Dead Sea,
your water boils at 101.4.
If you go to the top of
Mount Everest, it's 70.
You never boil potatoes there.
Well, you can, but
they'll never cook.
So how do you--
how does this get connected?
That's really the question.
What is-- so what is this?
Right.
Where does that-- where does
that dependence come from?
And that's where
we need something
called kinetic theory.
Now I'm not going to
teach you kinetic theory.
And I'm not going to say that
you responsible for knowing it.
But I'm showing
you what it means.
What kinetic theory does,
which you would learn in,
say like a thermal class, right.
Well, kinetic theory
does is it gives us
this relationship between how
many molecules have a given
energy, in this case, it's
a kinetic energy, right,
and the temperature.
That's what can in
theory does for us.
So let's see, if I had--
if I had to write this in a kind
of just simple dependence way,
what it's telling
us, in, general is--
so this would be
kinetic theory--
kinetic theory of
gases, if you want.
That's what we're
talking about there.
OK.
This would give
us the following.
This is what you get is that
the log of the fractions--
fraction of molecules with some
energy, E, OK, with energy--
I'll write it out just so
there's not confusion-- energy,
E, the log of that, the
natural log of that,
is going to go as that energy
divided by temperature.
It gives you a
connection between what
I'm plotting here really.
That's where that
plot comes from.
OK.
The fraction of molecules
with kinetic energy,
E, goes as that energy
divided by temperature.
The log of that.
That's what kinetic
theory gives me.
That fills it in,
except that I--
it still isn't vapor pressure.
Right.
This still isn't vapor pressure.
And so for that, you
need one more piece.
And that is given to us
by Clausius-Clapeyron.
So the Clausius-Clapeyron
equation--
ah-- Clapeyron-- does not--
I'm not going to derive it.
You don't need to
know how to derive it.
But it goes from the kinetic
theory to vapor pressures.
So this one tells us that
the log of the vapor pressure
equals minus--
and here we go-- this is the
next really important concept--
the heat of vaporization--
and we'll get to
this in a second--
divided by RT plus a constant.
So that's the
ideal gas constant.
That's the temperature.
And this is the enthalpy or
the heat of vaporization.
So it's the energy
to vaporize a liquid.
Good.
Now, often, this is
given in per mole.
So it would be like the
energy of vaporizing
a mole of a liquid,
but it's an energy.
It's an amount of energy
needed to turn it,
whatever you got to
put into it, to turn it
into a gas from a liquid.
That's that enthalpy
of vaporization.
And R is the ideal gas
constant, in this case.
You know, so if it's R--
if R is in the equation,
it's got to be per mole,
right, because it's
R. Remember, we've
already talked about that.
Since it's R, it's the
ideal gas constant.
So that's, now, OK, so that
is how you get between--
that is how you get
this relationship.
You get it, and, again, this
is an important equation.
You get it from the
kinetic theory gases,
but this is what the
outcome is for us.
This is what matters, is the
Clausius-Clapeyron equation.
And so, and so now,
you can actually now,
if somehow you knew
how much energy it
took to vaporize a
mole of this stuff,
well, now you've got a curve.
That's all I need to know,
right, is how much energy is--
so now, I can say, well,
let's see, that's OK--
I got-- I got, maybe butane
is going to go like this.
And then glycerol
might go like that.
Maybe this is propanol.
Right.
Propane, glycerol, and so on.
Yeah.
But I'm still
missing this concept.
So I can now get dependence,
but how do I get delta H?
That's the next
piece of the puzzle.
Right.
How do I get delta H?
OK.
So, you know, so far I've got
this really cool result, right.
I've got that P--
so far I've got that--
I'm going back to bowling--
I'm going back to boiling.
Right.
For boiling, I know that--
so the ion-- so P vapor is
related to the IMFs, right.
I know that P vapor is
related to the temperature.
And I know that the atmospheric
pressure is important.
Right.
Atmospheric pressure
is related to boiling.
Yeah.
OK.
That's redundant,
because you've got
to get higher than the
atmospheric pressure
to boiling.
That's how we defined it.
So, but, again, this
specific dependence
is what I wanted on
temperature, and I have it,
except that I now need to
know what this delta H is.
OK.
So here we go-- why is
this related to pizza?
Everything's related to
pizza at the end of the day.
But see, now we need
to talk about delta H,
and what it means.
And you know, the way--
the easiest way to
show what it means
is to plot how this
relates to phase change.
How heat, right, that's how
we're changing phase here
with temperatures.
We're changing the temperature.
We're adding heat
into the system.
What does it do?
Well, you know, so one type of
plot that you can make for that
would be temperature versus
thermal, thermal energy input.
Now a lot of times what
you'll see in textbooks
is they call that q.
It's an energy term.
So it's like in joules, right.
Let's say.
But it's how much thermal
energy you put it in,
then you can draw
it out like this.
Right.
So if you draw it out, then
you would have your phases.
So this would be like a gas,
a liquid, a solid, and these
would be phase changes.
This, and that.
So I'm adding thermal
energy into the system.
It's raising the
temperature of the system.
That's why these are going up.
But the solid is getting hotter,
and then, all of a sudden, it
melts.
OK.
Good.
So it melted.
It melts.
And then it's a liquid, and,
all of a sudden, it vaporizes.
Right.
Vaporize.
But you can go the other way.
If you go the other way,
it's condensation out here.
All right.
Or freezing in here.
Melting, freezing,
vaporization, condensation.
But I like to draw it this
way, because this way we're
going to see very
nicely what delta H is.
So here's-- now I'm going
to draw it with temperature
on the x-axis.
So temperature-- and
this is going to be H.
And I'm drawing this
as the thermal energy--
let's see, I'm going to
write it in the same terms--
right.
So this is thermal energy.
Now in this case,
thermal energy,
we use this thing called
enthalpy, enthalpy.
But you don't need to worry too
much about it, for this class,
you can think about it
as the thermal energy
content of the material.
So if I have a change
in that, wells,
it's because I've lost
or gained thermal energy.
Right.
If you take a
thermal class, you'll
learn a lot more about enthalpy.
And that this is true only
if you have constant pressure
conditions, but that's
not relevant here.
I just want you to
know, this is like this.
OK.
But this is the total thermal
energy in your material.
And by the way, you know,
q, heat, the word heat is q.
That is the definite-- heat
means thermal energy transfer.
Thermal energy transfer,
a flow of heat.
That makes sense.
But you cannot say that
this has 10 joules of heat.
No, don't say that.
You will sound like you're
from another school.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't have-- you
have that much enthalpy.
Yeah.
But not that much.
Heat is a transfer of
thermal energy, please.
OK.
Now here we go.
All right.
So let's suppose I
were to draw this.
Well, now I'm going
to have the same--
I'm going to have phases.
Right.
And so here we go,
here we go, here we go.
And this is my gas,
and this is my liquid,
and this is my solid.
There's a couple of
cool things, right.
So now-- so that's
the thermal energy, H.
But so now, if I
were to take part
of the solid like that, and just
look at it, while it's a solid.
I'm adding thermal energy to it.
I'm increasing its temperature.
We got a way to
relate those things.
It's called the heat capacity.
All right.
So if I look at that,
OK, I can do that.
Let's go here.
All right.
If I look at that, then
I can relate those by--
well, I'm using q, because
it's a change, right, that's
the change in the enthalpy.
All right.
That's the energy transfer.
It goes as the heat
capacity times the change
in the temperature.
That s just means it's the
heat capacity of the solid.
Literally, that's the
definition of heat capacity.
Right.
This would be like units
of joules per kelvin.
OK.
So and, example of heat
capacity, I love pizza,
and so an example of heat
capacity is the following.
You burn, hopefully, you don't.
But if you take it out of the
oven, and you take a bite,
right away, you will burn
the roof of your mouth
on the cheese.
On the cheese, because cheese
has a lot of water in it
compared to the crust.
And water has a really
high heat capacity.
What is heat capacity?
It's the capacity of it
to have thermal energy.
And the water has
a really high one,
and so, when you take
this out, everything's
at the same temperature
for just an instant.
They're all at the
same temperature.
If you eat it right
here, please don't, you
burn your mouth on the crust
the same way as on the cheese.
But since you're
waiting, now the crust
gives out-- it doesn't
have much heat capacity.
So it all goes away.
All that thermal energy
leaves very quickly
from the crust,
but not the cheese,
because it's got so much more.
And if we want to get a
little more serious about it,
we can talk about the oceans.
And so, I put this in here.
Because we talk a lot
about climate change, what
you're talking about are the
temperatures of the atmosphere.
We talk about that a lot.
But what gets sort
of shoved aside
is the temperature of the
ocean, and that is rising,
and it's not rising
that quickly, luckily,
but that's because the ocean
has such a high heat capacity.
That's where most of this
thermal energy is going.
It's going into the ocean.
Right.
And we need to start
talking about that
a whole lot more, because it's
a lot higher than it used to be.
This is the historical
reference, pretty flat.
A volcano erupts, 500 years
ago, you get a blip this big.
Now we're here.
Right.
So the amount of thermal energy
this ocean is holding for us
is very high.
OK.
Now so that's high capacity.
That's kind of an
important part,
but, look, the other
thing we have here-- ah,
I keep hitting the
wrong-- is this.
And that's what I
want to talk about.
This is that delta
H. Now in this case,
it's the change in
energy of fusion,
because you're fusing
to make a solid.
In this case, it's called
delta H of vaporization.
You could call it
condensation vaporization.
That's the thing we needed.
And now you see
it so beautifully.
All right.
You see it so beautifully right
there, because, now, you see--
so what is it that causes me
to need to put a lot of energy
into a material to change its
bonds so that it can vaporize?
It's all about the
bonding strength.
It's all about the--
everything comes to
the bonding strength.
Right.
And so I have these kind
of two things, right.
Within one phase,
within one phase,
I can relate delta H to delta T.
And that relationship is here.
I'm in the solid phase.
I can relate them.
That's actually
called sensible heat.
Sensible heat.
It's the energy that you
would give off when you cool,
or it's the energy that
you'd absorb when you heat.
But now I've got
this other thing,
which is at the phase
change, at the phase change.
Well, now, the temperature
doesn't change,
but I'm putting
all of this energy
in, or getting it all out.
That's what delta H is.
All right.
So delta T is 0, because
the temperature is constant.
And delta H is
sort of, generally,
called the latent
heat, latent heat.
If you're talking
about the phase
change between a
solid and liquid,
it's the heat of
fusion, heat of melting.
If you're talking about
between the liquid and gas
vaporization, or condensation.
So that's that energy change.
And it's related to, well,
what we've been talking about,
but here it isn't
a nice diagram.
Right.
Now, where do we go from here?
Well, there's something
so cool about this graph
that I can show
you really easily.
I can also tell
you how to do this,
which is that things can--
these are the phase change
transition temperatures,
but things don't need
to transition at those.
In fact, oftentimes, you
might get something like that.
Not as much in the gas,
but liquid to solid,
you certainly can get it.
This is called super cooled.
Why?
Because, for some reason,
[INAUDIBLE],, for some reason,
it's remained a liquid below
its phase change temperature.
Here's water, super cooled,
poured into a glass.
It's one of the most fun
things you can do in life.
There it is.
It's a liquid.
As soon as it hits the glass,
it's like, wait a second,
I want to be a solid.
I'm over here.
I need to be a solid.
And you can do this.
You can make--
I can tell you how to make it.
You can make super
cooled water at home.
It's really fun.
But that was what you're
doing there, now you know,
is you're bringing this
down below the phase change.
It's remaining liquid.
Now all of a sudden,
it hits the glass,
and, but what am I doing?
I need to solidify.
All right.
OK.
This is the reason why all this
matters is heat is a big deal.
90%, you now, this is--
you can study this.
There are wonderful
charts to study.
But depending on
what you want to do,
heat is almost always involved.
Heat being a transfer
of thermal energy.
And so 90% of the
current energy budget,
basically, goes through
the middle in some way.
That's a lot.
But then, if you
look at things like
this, which you shouldn't,
because you can't read it,
but if you blow up--
these are all the
inputs on the left,
all the ways we make energy.
Here's how we use it.
And here's the result.
Here's where I want to get the
punch line is, rejected energy.
Whatever these units,
doesn't matter, it's 60%.
What is rejected energy mean?
Wasted.
All this precious fossil
fuel stuff we're burning
and all the solar
energy we're collecting,
anything we're doing here,
60% of it goes into heat,
wasted heat.
And so the reason
why this matters
is because there
are these materials
that we can use to try
to capture some of that.
Right.
There are materials we can use
to try to capture some of that,
and it all comes
down to chemistry.
These are called phase
change materials.
And if you plot the melting
temperature, that's this--
that's this melting
temperature, right, Tm,
versus how much of its delta
H, how much delta H you have,
you get all sorts of
classes and materials.
But, you know, so you might want
a certain melting temperature
from wherever you're operating,
but then you might not
get a high enough
delta H, or you
might want really high delta
Hs, but then the thing doesn't
melt until 700c,
which is way too high.
So we got to fill this out.
We need materials here.
That's a call to chemistry.
So then, it all has to
do with the phase change.
It's a weird name.
These are called phase
change materials,
but that's true
of all materials.
But, here, when you're talking
about storing thermal energy,
we use the term phase
change materials.
OK.
Now the last concept, and
I'll just touch on, and then
spend a little time on Friday
on, is the concept of a map.
These are maps.
But you can go even bigger.
And back in the day, back in
the day, PVT was a big deal.
You went to a party,
you were going
to talk about PVT. You were.
And you know, and
so, everybody had
their own way of looking at it.
Gay-Lussac, P versus T.
But look, if I do P
versus T, and hold volume
constant, right, I might get
like a line there, like P--
if this is pressure, all
right, and this is temperature,
you might get something like
P versus T is a straight line,
if you hold other
stuff constant.
Right.
That's good.
But that's not what I'm
interested in today.
I'm interested in where
the phase boundaries are.
Right.
This is a materials map, and
it gives me the boundary,
that's what this is all about.
That's what this was all about.
Because, look, that's why
I went through all this.
You boil.
What is boil?
Phase change.
You boil when Pv is greater
than P at [INAUDIBLE]..
So that is the phase boundary.
It's when you have both the
gas and the liquid coexisting.
Where is it?
Ah, there it is,
because I can get
my pressure of
vaporization, if I only
know this, or vice versa.
Right.
And then I get that.
It's up here.
That's the phase boundary.
Oh, yeah, that's all cool,
but this is where it's at.
I want to know where
stuff changes phase.
All right.
And, of course,
you can go further.
And I've got to show
you something here.
There's a couple more
things about-- these
are called phase
diagrams, right.
These are maps of materials,
and they are beautiful things,
and incredibly important.
And there's a couple
last points, one of which
I want to share now, and then
the other I'll share on Friday.
But the one I want to share
now is the triple point.
So look at this.
Here's the gas
liquid boundary line.
That's what we've
been talking about.
You also got the solid
liquid boundary line.
That's here.
You got gas liquid
here, delta H-
here's delta H. You
also have sublimation.
So you go straight
from a solid to a gas,
and you have deposition.
You go straight from a
gas-- but look at this.
There's one point where
they all co-exist.
One, and only one
where all three phases
exist at the same time.
That's pressure.
That's temperature.
And what's so cool about
this is there's only one
for this material, and so it,
actually, is a really nice way
to have a repeatable,
reproducible point, which
I'll get to in a second.
But first you got to see this.
This is a triple point.
And what they're
doing is they're
lowering the pressure
and the temperature.
They're changing both.
You could just do this
with one or the other.
Yeah.
There it is.
OK.
How did they get it to boil?
Lower the pressure.
You now know why.
You lower the atmosphere
inside the container.
You lowered that, so
you went like this.
You went down.
And all of a sudden, you
converted some of the liquid
to gas, because you
went down in pressure.
And then you said, well,
OK, but wait a second,
I'm only seeing
these two phases.
So let me do this, and
go over that way, getting
closer, closer, OK,
what's happening now?
Then do this, right?
And you're trying to find
this special point here.
And they're going close to it.
They're going close to it.
And then a couple minutes go
by, that, look, it's freezing.
It's freezing.
It's-- but wait a second, I
thought I said triple point.
And I did.
It's boiling and freezing
at the same time.
It is boiling and
freezing at the same time.
Yes, that is actually
what all materials can do.
That is incredible.
Somebody just said what.
Thank you for making my day.
That makes my day.
That is a triple point.
We got a one or two more things
to talk about phase diagrams.
We'll do that on Friday.
Have a great rest of your day.
This is where we left off.
And so, I want to
start right here.
And because a triple point
is just so incredibly cool,
I've found another random video,
and I thought I'd show that.
So this is where we left off.
And here it is.
And what they're
doing, they might
be controlling the
temperature, they're
definitely controlling
the pressure.
All right.
They have a liquid in here.
Now watch what happens.
We know now from
the phase diagram
that you can find those
boundaries on the diagram.
So they're lowering the
pressure, and at some point,
yeah, nothing's going happen.
There.
OK.
Now it's playing.
And so at some point, this
is going to start to freeze,
because I'm crossing
over the boundary.
All right.
I'm crossing over the boundary.
And so when you cross over, when
you get to a phase boundary,
you've got two
phases coexisting.
Oh, and there it
starts freezing,
so you've got the liquid and
the solid phase coexisting,
but there's--
but now can it coexist
with, also, the gas.
And at one point of pressure
and temperature, it can.
There it is.
It's kind of boiled
a little bit.
I like this one, because
it kind of goes big boil.
So here it is.
It's trying to freeze,
and now it's boiling.
And now, watch, it'll refreeze.
All right.
And then it's going
to boil again.
It's all three phases at
exactly the same time.
So you can Google it.
There it is.
It boiled, again.
And then it's going
to freeze, again.
It can do all three at once.
That is cool.
All right.
And how do we get there?
How do we get there?
Well, what I thought--
on Wednesday was the first
time I told you there's
two new lectures this fall.
That was the first
time I gave that one.
That was one of them.
The other one will be on
the chemistry of batteries.
And because it's
new, I, you know,
I want to make
sure that you feel
your oneness with the
concepts that we learned.
And so I have made
some summary slides
for you, that I'm not going
to take time to go through.
But that tells you
how we got to here.
That's the end of the
lecture on Wednesday.
And I want to make sure
that how we got there,
and what the key points were.
There are five key points.
And I've created a slide here,
again, this is Wednesday,
so I'm not going to go
through this in detail,
but I'll leave
this in your notes.
One point was boiling and vapor
pressure, and what that means.
The second point is the vapor
pressure versus temperature,
which we get from kinetic theory
and Clausius-Clapeyron gives us
the relationship between
that vapor pressure
and the temperature through this
thing called the vaporization.
The thermal-- this,
remember, this change
in the thermal energy.
Right, this delta H,
this change in enthalpy.
OK.
And by the way, you can--
these are these like vapor
pressure versus temperature
curves we drew.
You can take two of
them, for example,
that gets rid of the constant
in that equation, two
pressures, two vapor
pressures, two temperatures.
You can calculate that
vaporization energy.
That's that interrelationship
we talked about.
The third point is
the thermal energy
that delta H is related
to the phase change.
It is the energy of
the phase change.
Right.
So we talked about that.
And then, I couldn't
find a good--
so I just drew this myself
here with fancy PowerPoint--
and what you can see
here is a heating curve.
And you can draw it
in two different ways.
You can draw it as the
temperature versus enthalpy,
or you could draw
it as the energy
input versus temperature.
These are equivalent.
It's just not mm, and mm.
Right.
And then, in this, you can
find all so much information,
like there's that delta H
between the phases, right.
Here is the liquid phase,
the gas, the solid.
And then, if you're
in a single phase,
we talked about that
change in enthalpy
related to the heat capacity.
If you're at the phase change,
the temperature doesn't change,
but you're putting a
lot of energy into it.
And that, finally, got
us to phase diagrams.
This is where we left off.
So I'm leaving this all here
for you to look at if you want.
It's kind of a summary
of Wednesday's lecture,
the key points.
This is that two-phase curve.
Right.
And this is-- on these
curves, remember,
the phase diagram is a map.
It's this beautiful
map of the material.
Right.
It's a map of the chemistry
of the thermodynamics
of the phases of whether
it's a gas, liquid, or solid.
And these coexistence curves
are where two phases coexist.
Right.
So you see at these
temperatures and pressures,
and that's why we started the
lecture talking about vapor
pressure, because the vapor
pressure is such a nice way
to get into the idea of how
a material changes phase
from liquid to gas,
which is what we did.
And then, we also
talked about how
that triple point, that's the
video that we left off with.
And then there's one last
thing I didn't mention,
which is that there's
this critical point here.
What's happening out there?
What's happening out there
is really interesting, too.
There is a temperature,
right, above which--
so there is-- if you keep
going up in temperature,
there is a critical point where
this boundary just disappears.
It stops.
The liquid, there's the
liquid, and the gas,
and now there's no line.
What happened?
What happened is, you've
reached a temperature
where it, basically, can't
exist as a liquid anymore.
If you keep going, the thermal
energy is just too high.
But the pressure
is too high, too.
So this is a different phase.
And this phase it out here
is called supercritical.
This is called supercritical,
where the material
has properties of both.
That's really cool.
Right.
So this material
has maybe properties
like it can flow like
a gas, all right,
but it's got a higher
density than a gas,
but it's still
lighter than a liquid.
And it's that same material.
It's that same material,
whatever it is, water.
Right.
That's called supercritical.
So these lines
can end like that.
And that's called
the critical point.
Now, there, you know,
there are many reasons
why these maps are important.
I thought I'd give you
one which is strawberries.
Because, if you go and you buy--
some of us like to
buy like dried fruit--
but if I take strawberries and
I leave them out on the counter,
they're not going
to look like this.
You know, how do you know that?
Well, you know that
from the phase diagram,
because if I draw my
temperature and pressure,
and I've got some phase diagram
that looks like this, right.
And so now, you know
solid, liquid, gas.
Well, you know, I could--
if I just-- if I just tried
to dry these things out,
that's this.
That's that.
But so, I'm-- maybe, maybe, I'm
going to, or maybe I want to do
this.
Oh, that's even worse.
What if I go like this.
I'm going to heat
the strawberries up.
I'm making jam.
No.
That's not jam.
Right.
That's nice kind of
maybe still solid,
it's not like mushy and gooey.
How do I get it?
Well, you use the phase
diagram, of course.
You go-- because this
kind of phase change,
going across that
phase boundary,
it creates a lot of
disruption in the material.
It creates a lot of disruption.
You saw it, right, this boiling.
So if you do that for the water
inside of the strawberries,
you're going to destroy all the
framework of the good stuff,
right.
So what you do is you freeze it.
You go this way, and
then you go that way.
If you do that,
now the solid as it
sublimates is much
less of a kind
of violent,
disturbing phenomenon
to the surrounding
matrix of strawberry.
And so you get these freeze
dried fruit that way.
It's much less disturbing,
destructive way
to get rid of the water.
That's called freeze dried.
You can also go the
other-- if I go out here,
I've got all sorts of uses to
use this supercritical region.
I've got all sorts of ways
where that becomes useful.
That's how coffee
is decaffeinated,
because it's a different
phase of this material.
So the phase maps give
us this information.
They tell us how we can engineer
properties and materials
by engineering their phases.
Right.
And if you pull out
another thing, you know--
a lot of the textbooks
and what we did
is we look at the phase
diagram down here.
But if you pull
out, you also can
see how complex materials are.
All right.
This is water.
We've been focusing on
this part of phase diagram,
now you plot it.
Water has 17 phases, 17, not 3.
And just two years ago,
the 17th was discovered,
and it's a very, very
light form of ice.
All right.
So you can get all sorts of
really important information
about materials by looking
at their phase diagrams.
You can compare
different materials,
like this is the phase
diagram of CO2 versus water.
And you can learn
about sort of where
their critical points are.
You can see all the
slope here in water is--
most material slope like that.
Water slopes like that.
And that's because
of hydrogen bonds.
Because the hydrogen
bonds make it
so that the solid is less dense
than the liquid, which means,
if I squeeze on it, I can--
then I go to the liquid.
That's really weird.
If I squeeze on
this, it's more soft.
But here, it goes-- it can
cross a phase boundary.
That's very unique to
water, and the fish
are very happy about
that, because ice floats.
OK.
Now, OK, now, so that's the
kind of last part of the phase
diagram stuff.